judges at the international court of
justice are hearing arguments from
Russia and Ukraine about moscow's claims
it launched its Invasion to prevent
genocide Ukraine brought the case to the
United Nations highest court days after
Russia invaded last year Kiev accuses
Moscow of abusing international law by
falsely alleging genocide in eastern
Ukraine Russia wants the case to be
thrown out and objects to the Court's
Jurisdiction
Ukraine is not accusing Russia of
committing genocide
Ukraine is also not accusing Russia of
failing to prevent or punish genocide
on the contrary
Ukraine insists no genocide has occurred
that alone should be enough to reject
the case
because according to the courts
jurisprudence
if there was no genocide they cannot be
a violation of the genocide convention
all right Jeffrey nice uh joins us from
Canterbury in the United Kingdom he is
Emeritus Gresham professor of law and
the former League prosecutor of the
sobram losovic trial for the United
Nations at the international criminal
Tribunal for Yugoslavia good to have you
with us sir so first of all what do you
make of the prospects of this case being
thrown out of course as Russia is
pursuing
I'm not sure that I'm yet in a position
to assess the prospect it was a very
strong decision in the first place in
favor of Ukraine and that was before we
reached the merits stage and I think
what will be most interesting in the
developing argument over the next few
days is not just the position of Ukraine
and Russia or the Russian Federation but
also the 30 other states which include
the United Kingdom but not I think the
United States of America who are allowed
to intervene and to make arguments so
impossible to assess the outcome
although the original decision was a
very strong one
I think for your listeners and viewers
it's important to understand what this
is and what this isn't uh although we
might like we would all probably like a
nice straightforward Universal system of
international law that means you can say
somebody's committing a war crime and
stop them doing it life isn't like that
it's all bits and pieces and the bit
that the the international court of
justice is and can deal with is alleged
breaches of conventions it's not a
criminal court it's not going to make a
criminal finding
but what Ukraine was successful in doing
in raising at the court and now having
argued was to get the court to say that
Russia must stop
its war-like and warring attitudes and
actions in Ukraine now that's a very
important provisional finding and if
it's confirmed by the full court even
though it had the court has no powers of
enforcement and we know enforcement will
be blocked at the security Council by
The veto of Russia
that finding would be extremely powerful
in the world as a whole so we must
follow the arguments with great care and
await the conclusion with great interest
we must follow how long do you think
this process is going to take to get a
final ruling from the full court I
well I think I had this morning that the
final hearings are on the 25th and I
imagine they'll then take a month or
maybe more or several months maybe to
reach a decision but they acted pretty
quickly the last time so one would
imagine that they will see the
urgency required here and act and act
pretty quickly here
all right um and I think okay sorry I
was going to say going back to the
earlier point you made even if the court
upholds the provisional finding that
this war should end that Russia should
should stop the war
we know
that this can't be enforced right
practically speaking it's going to go to
the security Council be vote vetoed by
the Russians what practical effect does
it have
well
it practically affected it it has is
that other countries May
be reinforced in their determination for
example to apply sanctions on Russia or
to carry on providing Weaponry in
support of you Crane and of course it
leaves right it would leave Russia as a
pariah state so
um although there's no powers of
enforcement in a sense how could there
be powers of enforcement unless you have
an international police force and an
international Army
are finding that
um its inversion was not justified its
war is not justified will have
considerable potential follow-on effects
and those of us following perhaps the
Western arguments in favor of Ukraine we
would say very positive effects most
importantly I think in sanctions and in
the continuing supply of weapons to your
groin
does it at all increase the legal
exposure of some of the Russian
officials if the if the full court goes
the direction of the provisional Court
um I'm not sure
that it would really because there's a
separate process going on at the
international Court Criminal Court which
is a criminal court and which does have
jurisdiction over
um this particular Conflict by reason of
submission to jurisdiction by Ukraine
and we know that that court has already
issued arrest warrants against Putin and
one other
um in respect to violations of uh war
crimes and crimes against humanity
so it is pursuing a criminal case
against individuals so far to have been
identified but there may be many more to
follow
we know that Ukraine is pursuing and
successfully pursuing its own criminal
proceedings
and although in any of those proceedings
a favorable decision by this court might
be prayed in Aid might be referred to I
don't think but I could be wrong but I
don't think at this stage that a
determination by the international court
of justice would necessarily have
finding value in the other courts not
least because there's plenty of evidence
that they will have gathered and are
relying on and they might not require
the detailed decision of a civil court
as effectively it is but a court that
deals with breaches of treaty uh in
support of its criminal procedures but
that I'm afraid is also something we
must put on hold because Ukraine was
very inventive in turning to the court
in its application to have its right not
to be falsely accused of you of genocide
as you explained in your helpful opening
to have it litigated at this court and
so imaginative lawyering or imaginative
use of law by lawyers not something we
often see but really welcome when we do
see it uh just may lead to this decision
being of a wider implication than I
suggest all right a lot to keep our eyes
on then thank you so much for sharing
your thoughts and Analysis on that